it's webon time ladies and gentlemen John how are
you spider first more K the son man Cody Johnson
owns Valentine's Day now the bondage is whips
oh my God have we hit the 15 to 20 second Mark
yet cuz that's what's required are you excited to
talk about Ezekiel Sims is he in this that's what
I read on Twitter Spider-Man number 30 is Ezekiel
Sims as invented by J Michael shinski illustrated
by John meter Junior ever felt like your browser
is as flat as the deepest understanding of marine
biology welcome aboard the Opera GX not your
average browser teaming up with jmv Opera GX
allows you to dive into the world of the boys
customiz your browser themes colors and even
sounds just like homelanders laser eyes this
modded look is dazzling exclusive to oper GX
users there's V the vot International's inor
social platform it's for fans catch up with
characters like Marie and Emma as they climb the
rankings of God you feel like Starlight got you
through the darkness of boring browsers head to
the GX store flip your entire browser universe
and be the beacon of coup and if you want to have
more power over your setup than Andre Anderson
there's a social media sidebar for everything else
Twitter Tik Tok Instagram and more vots approved
of course switching over doesn't need super
strength no no import bookmarks history and
even extensions in a Flash faster than a train on
a good day thanks to oper GX for sponsoring this
video level up your browsing game folks download
oper GX and oh yeah don't miss gen V on Prime
video hey come on get your stuff let's go
right away oh Sydney Sweeney waa that was
a cool shot practical Spider-Man damn damn this
like upgrade yeah she got pruned from the web of
life this going to be a fourstar picture
a week ago I spent my life racing against
time I'm going to help you out today okay try
people who are running out of it one moment
changed everything oh my god spider baby is
that M Parker is that little M Parker think
it was is that Peter Parker I don't understand
what's happening I've been having Vision I knew
he was going to die preck good shot there's
some good shots in there New York City is a
whole new level of crazy these days do that
again he's shoeless it might be Ezekiel Sims
New York City is a whole new level of crazy
these days final spider destination get off
the train that man's trying to kill you
why who are you what is going on oh my
God I can see the future Sydney Sweeny and
glasses me likey what the hell she didn't
see that coming that's not how it works it's
not how being psychic works I've seen that
man before so who is he Ezekiel Sims with
my mom when she was researching spiders
right before she died just toing through
that little web you live in my building
you're the paramedic yeah you almost ran me
over you don't think this is weird how we're
all connected I do I think it's weird honestly
like the least weird thing that's happened all
day I have no idea what those girls have
come can see into the future he's trying
to change what happen hell yeah man jul
get down this a cool Direction some of
this it's got that Sony cheese I love was
almost so different if you want you have
to trust me get ready I they're in New
York and Spider-Man's actually swinging
around you're showing off maybe a
little I'm very excited do you know Spider-Man
supped to play taste in New York and this movie
knows it yeah that feels so like New York Webhead
it does it's got that for sure look at the jness
I'm so excited vibrating off of coy right now how
many Spider-Man leave New York immediately to go
to Europe or to go to space this has some flavor
of New York far from hope all of the homecoming
he was in the suburbs and then and in no way
home they like took him away from New York so
he could have emotional beats adjacent that was
great John please oh it's more than time in in
honesty this does look really fun and it's been a
minute since we've had one of these Sony trailers
it feels like forever ago we were watching the
Craven trailer and uh this does like you said
have that uh kind of cheesy but also intriguing
quality this feels tangible this feels like a
movie out of a different time a little bit and
and oddly enough is as much as people dog Sony
I do think that they have like an oddly uh I
don't know invigorated version of this universe
they keep you know proliferating for us and uh
I as much as I think that that is in some ways
disjointed the disjointedness is also like part of
the style that has become endearing excited to see
all these different characters team up could be
very silly but also seems like it's probably going
to give you some of the Spider-Man stuff that's
become like complicated out of existence lately
so I'm I'm cautiously optimistic this has that
B movie cheese that I love from Sony especially
in their trailers the cast looks reasonably fine
one thing that I was surprised by there actually
seems like there's a lot of cool Purpose with a
lot of their uh action shot they shot the movie
it doesn't look like a lock off frame they like
those hoad shots I think a lot of the other Sony
Spider-Man movies kind of look like they're all
shot by the same person and this feels like it
was shot by someone with some intentional Vision
Dakota Johnson's delivery was not my favorite in
the trailer but I've seen her in a lot of things
that I have really really really enjoyed her in
it's just a trailer so I'm just going to wait for
the actual movie itself it's not like the Sony
Spiderman movies give out the best performances
out of great actors all the time anyway we'll
see how this goes but yeah I mean it looks like
uh a little bit Whimsical I like the look of the
Spiderwoman outfit it's cdy Sweeney man I love
her in euphoria think I've ever seen her in and
she's really talented and she's hot as hell too
so you get the combination of talent and hotness
and you got my ticket baby just delaying the time
so Koy can ramble wait who's Adam Scott playing I
think he's Peter Parker I think he's so excited
I think I don't think he's Peter Parker I think
he's gonna be her universe as Peter Parker and
I think I think the web of life is keeping her
protecting May Parker from existence I thought
there was baby Peter Parker in this he's got a
baby par sure he's not Ben Parker uncle that'd
be Ben Parker I mean she is old in the comics
but they're using the young version of who Ezekiel
Sims Ezekiel Sims is a professor uh professorial
element of Peter Parker's life that is introduced
an Amazing Spider-Man number 30 he's a man who
introduces the concept of the spider totem he's
got this great concept of there is an element of
the people that get bit by the spider that is uh
predetermined so they have this totem that's why
Spider-Man has a lot of animal themed villains you
got scorpion you got vulture all those things is
because the spider totem is an element that draws
this in so did the spider bite Peter Parker giving
him the powers or did the radiation uh basically
allow that to go through because Spider-Man Peter
Parker was already predestined to fit with that
radiation like chicken egg power cause so uh
Ezekiel Sims is this man who kind of guides
him through the spider totem concept which is
uh this idea that leads to the spider verse
that leads to the web of life so my concept
is that we see obviously she's Tethered to the
Web of Life she can see things she's you know
Deon Sawa and Final Destination but I think what
ends up happening is her universe's Spider-Man
uh is meant to have this baby who's May Mayday
Parker who was very important later on and that
baby I think in the trailer is going to be young
Mayday and that one little quick shot is is him I
believe is Peter Parker but we've got like Aran
ar ar who's another Spiderwoman who we see with
the the legs coming out who is another version
of a future um Spider-Man Spiderwoman and then
obviously we have a Spiderwoman herself played by
Sydney Sweeney who's another universes so I think
we'll we'll see a bit of multiversal stuff that
will tie to the web of life and that's basically
going to be Dakota Johnson's job I wouldn't
be surprised if at some point we see in the
future like you know old in the chair so we can
kind of see what all happens but I think by the
end of this I me obviously got to age you up but
uh I think by the end of this we see that the web
of life is interconnected and this might I don't
know if it's going to tie into things going from
2D to 3D from animated to live action but they
could glimpse into some of that here uh and I'm
wondering if Ezekiel Sims is going to be a Twist
like if he's the bad spider uh it does look like
they're playing with the idea that he he's not
all there I'm wondering if they'll make it Kane
maybe they'll make it like you know another
Peter Parker they could play with the idea of
instead of a clone like a mutilated Peter from
another Multiverse I don't know if they'll deal
with clones in here but there's a lot of potential
to tie into the lore of Spider-Man that wouldn't
get told another thing and what I liked most was
it's shot like a Spider-Man movie like they give
you some angles and some web swinging and some
New York which I was so excited about but it
feels like and this is a compliment The Amazing
Spider-Man cinematography where it felt like you
were thrust into the world as opposed to watching
the world and I really dug that yeah as a uh Sony
Marvel movie like guy I love that they have
cornered the market on the 2000s like I love
that like 2000s movies they used to like they
used to play more like 2000s movies were like
let's just see when comic movies would come out
in the 2000s it was like let's see what insane
angles we can get away with because it's a comic
movie this feels like they're like let's dance
but we have technology so I mean that looked like
a lot of fun to me it looked like you know we're
getting a beautiful array of the different spider
women tone and it could allow for some really
fun tie-ins to things in the future if this does
well there's certain women we got mattye Franklin
Cassandra Webb and Julia Carpenter spiderwomen so
they're all different spider women I mean I mean
you know Cassandra Webb is is mad Madam web but in
the comics Madam web is actually also invented by
John Jr like Ezekiel Sims but much later on like
30 years later big career John J she is a usually
an older character that is portrayed as like a
soothsayer kind of the blind soothsayer element
of Mythology sitting in the web like perceiving
all bit of a profit Spider-Man goes to her in the
Animated Series very famously a lot of people
know her from the Animated Series but in the
newer comics in the last 20 years they've deaged
her she's a bit more of a spy she's a little more
playful they're going with that version clearly
with Dakota Johnson uh Maddie Franklin is the
niece of J Jonah Jameson it'd be really fun if
they use the Nexus being concept and they've got
JK Simmons in this as her uncle because she's like
the wealthy niece that uses like you know the the
the connections through that to kind of become
a different Spiderwoman she's the woman with the
uh The Superior Spider-Man esque arms uh she was
a short-lived run I think John burn invented her
a very iconic fixture of comic books and she's
a lot of fun but a very different a little more
sassy version of a Spiderwoman uh and then Julia
Carpenter is like your classic injected with a
mix of like plants and Spider Venom like that
more scientific like a nefarious plot to Creator
Spiderwoman and I think that's going to be our
our Sydney Sweeney with the black and white suit
we see very briefly and basically she is your
agent type like she's gonna be more of your your
cop on the edge uh so it's it's giving us uh the
industrialist the Spy the soothsayer so they're
all doing different elements in this case um I
believe all of them are going to be from Earth
616 which in the comic books is our is our main
our sacred timeline I'm wondering if they're
going to make it so the Sony designation is a
different number it wouldn't surprise me if in
my opinion the MCU is Earth 19999 but Kevin feige
calls it 616 those the comic should be separate
universes but I'm wondering if they'll establish
a Sony universe number designation they'll all
be from that one universe and it' be interesting
to see if Ezekiel is from a different one or if
he's from a universe that might tie into beyond
the spiderverse or if they'll do something where
they acknowledge the Marvel 616 and a Spider-Man
there but I maintain even if we have him as Ben
Parker I think we're going to find out that maybe
he is a Peter Parker clone Peter Parker brother
Peter something's going to tie into Peter where
it's going to be a reveal I think maybe he goes
by his middle name Peter Benjamin Parker is Peter
Parker's name um so either way I think that's May
Parker dude he could become Ben Riley somewhere
down if if he if he changes his name to Riley
at any point in this the amount of [__] I will
lose they're going to have to have a HazMat team
gon to be so excited all over the Ben Riley's my
boy and there's gonna be a lot of [__] uh yeah
this is this to me is is it's going to be the
Easter eggs that you want out of these movies
but they're so specifically Niche for people
like me that it won't Ru continuity this feels
like they made it for Spider-Man fans to just
go like oh my God they did that and we're never
going to worry about it over here and I for
that I thank them well I'm just excited for
a self-serious Spider-Man Sony movie you know
that's all I care about it's all I care about
right now and uh in a day and age where uh you
know we just had a female Le comic book movie
that is not doing that great at the box office I
hope this skyrockets and dominates and I'm going
to say I like it in advance right now get ahead of
it get ahead of the curb I've already decided I've
already I love it favorite one I think it kept
its release date right February all right let's
hope so dude we need February we need a movie in
2024 to happen Al righty guys well what did you
think about the trailer are you excited for it are
you excited as this guy over here Dakota Johnson
owns Valentine's Day now the bond just webs true
50 Shades of webs 50 stades of webs the webs are
gray